me siento bastante emocionado porque
llegamos al último examen del s
estamos en el examen número 8 y estamos
en la sección número 2 y este es el
primer vídeo así que empezaremos por el
primer problema manos a la obra primer
problema dice lo siguiente el costo
total de tres lapiceros iguales es de
cuatro pesos con cincuenta centavos es
de 450 si el costo de cada lapicero
aumenta en 50 centavos cuando gustaran
cinco de ellos con el nuevo precio ok
vamos a ver el costo de tres lapiceros
el costo de tres lapiceros y le voy a
poner tres l 3 l de lapiceros es igual a
450 esto es lo mismo que 450 ok y 7 aquí
despejamos el costo del lapicero pues
voy a obtener que el lapicero va a ser
igual a 450 a 450 y esto dividido entre
3 porque con 3 pago
50 y esto es exactamente lo mismo que un
peso con 50 centavos 150 ok
después aumentan el precio del 50
centavos así que a esto le voy a
aumentar 50 centavos
le voy a aumentar 50 centavos porque eso
aumentó el precio por lo tanto llegamos
a 2 pesos a 2 pesos ahora cada lapicero
cuesta dos pesos este es el nuevo precio
y ahora lo que nos preguntan para
finalizar es cuánto costarán cinco de
ellos cuánto van a costar cinco de ellos
cinco nuevos lapiceros por lo tanto voy
a multiplicado por 5 porque me voy a
tomar el 5 de ellos y esto es lo mismo
que 10 pesos 10 perros es decir que en
total voy a pagar 10 pesos y ya está la
respuesta de este problema es el inciso
e de lujo
vamos el problema número 2 espero que me
quepa justo aquí problema número 2 y
tiene la siguiente tabla aquí tengo a x
y aquí tengo a james y x va variando
desde los siguientes valores
1 1 2 3 y 4 1 2 3 y 4 y en ya tengo 3 3
7 11 y 15 11 y 15 de lujo 2 a 3 y 4 de
lujo y lo que me preguntan es cuál de
las siguientes ecuaciones lineales
describe esta relación bueno podríamos
tal vez sacar la pendiente y después
sacar la orden al origen y hacer todo
todo esto con mucha calma pero lo que se
me ocurre es que tal vez sea mucho más
rápido o al menos voy a hacerlo más
entretenido si voy verificando inciso
por inciso vamos a ver el inciso a el
inciso a me dice que es igual a x + 1
vamos a ver si de esta manera acabamos
de una manera más rápida sí que es igual
a x más uno me quedaría que uno más uno
en definitiva no es 3 1 1 2 3 y por
tanto no cumple ni siquiera con el
primer punto con el primer par de
valores por lo tanto esta no sería mi
respuesta
así de fácil quito la respuesta del
inciso a vamos a ver el inciso b b dice
que es igual a x + 4 x 4 y no no eso
tampoco es cierto porque fíjate bien uno
más cuatro no me va a dar tres de hecho
me da algo mucho más grande que 35 por
lo tanto esto tampoco es una respuesta
correcta inciso c se recuerda que se
tienen que cumplir para cada uno de
estos puntos para cada una de estas
parejas de valores o bien es igual a 3 x
esto en un principio parece funcionar
porque fíjate bien si yo tengo a si x
vale 11 x 33 y en este punto si funciona
sin embargo cuando me tomo el siguiente
punto el siguiente valor de x 3 por 12 6
y no llegamos a 7 entonces está casi
llega mi respuesta pero no no es mi
respuesta correcta
porque no cumple todos los puntos inciso
6 inciso b vamos al inciso de dice james
es igual a 4 x o que ya está en
definitiva no es y tú y yo sabemos que
no es porque cuando x vale 1 tenemos que
llegar al valor de 3 no al valor de 4
entonces ésta no es y parece ser que ya
encontramos mi respuesta en mi respuesta
debe de ser el insistió en si no me
equivoqué y es igual a 4 x menos 1 ok
vamos a ver si funciona me queda en un
principio si x vale 14 por unas 4 - 1
estrés se cumple si x vale 24 por 12 8
menos 197 se cumple si x vale 3 4 por 3
es 12 - uno es 11 de lujo y si x vale 4
4 por 4 16 menos unos 15 ya está se
cumple para cada pareja de números o
para cada punto de los que yo tengo aquí
y entonces mi respuesta es el inciso 4 x
menos 1 y bueno ahora sí voy a borrar el
pizarrón adiós a estos dos problemas y
vamos
problema número 3 el problema número 3
que dice lo siguiente de hecho tenemos
un par de circunferencias como esta
la primera la voy a hacer de color
amarillo tengo una circunferencia como
está ok algo más o menos así y tengo
otra circunferencia pero la voy a poner
de otro color la voy a poner de este
color tengo otras circunferencia más o
menos así otra circunferencia más o
menos así ok de tal manera que ésta se
ve que es más grande que esta de aquí y
bueno si estos son los puntos en donde
tenemos a los centros justo este es el
punto a ok este de acá es el punto b
donde donde se tocan nudos los dos
círculos que por cierto son tangentes
tangentes en el punto b y después tengo
am déjame agarrar aquí mi herramienta de
las rectas
tengo hasta acá que es el centro de mi
otra circunferencia que por cierto le
voy a poner el nombre de ese este ese ok
déjame ponerlo justo por acá este c
ok para no confundirnos y de una vez voy
a poner algo de nombres voy a decir que
este radio este radio se llama r 1 r 1
ok y este radio se llama r 2 r2 ok y lo
que me dice el problema es que la
distancia que hay de hace es decir r1 r2
son 6 unidades la distancia que hay de
aquí hasta acá todo esto son 6 unidades
ok y además me dicen que el perímetro de
la circunferencia de amarillo am le voy
a poner circunferencia la circunferencia
de amarillo es dos veces la
circunferencia de color azul la
circunferencia de color azul es ese
radio 2 por lo tanto le voy a poner de
circunferencia 2 ya esta circunferencia
1 aunque los colores nos vayan guiando
y la circunferencia 1 o el perímetro de
este círculo de amarillo es dos veces el
perímetro para la circunferencia de este
círculo de azul ok y entonces lo que me
preguntan es cuánto vale r2 yo lo que
quiero saber es el valor de r2 ok ahora
para obtener el valor de rd 2 que te
parece si primero pensamos bueno primero
aquí tenemos una ecuación que se ve
luego luego el valor de r 2 más el valor
de r 1 la suma de estos dos eses
entonces los voy a poner aquí r 2 más r
1 es igual a 6 la suma de los dos radios
es 6 porque es la distancia de a hace
esta ecuación me va a servir tarde o
temprano ahora yo seré 2 pero aquí tengo
solamente una ecuación con una incógnita
así que como podemos sacar r 2
bueno pues fijándonos en lo que nos
dicen justo aquí arriba c 1 es igual a
dos veces 2 el perímetro de la
circunferencia de amarillo es el doble
del perímetro de la circunferencia de
azul eso quiere decir a que si nosotros
pensamos en c-1
vamos a calcular la circunferencia 1 o
el perímetro de este círculo de amarillo
bueno pues por nuestra fórmula sabemos
que esto es exactamente lo mismo que dos
veces pi por el radio pero en este caso
tenemos el radio 12 veces spears por el
radio 1 ok y si nosotros pensamos ahora
en la circunferencia número 2 pues la
circunferencia número 2 la podemos
obtener con la fórmula que siempre no
sabemos cómo dos veces pi por el radio 2
por el radio 2 por el radio 2 de lujo y
lo que nosotros tenemos es esta igualdad
de aquí así que qué te parece si la
utilizamos justo ahorita voy a aplicar
esta igualdad que tengo aquí y me queda
que ese 1 es decir a donde lo pongo aquí
lo voy a poner que dos veces pi por r 1
esto es igual a 2 a 2 que multiplica
hace todos pero se 12 es todo esto de
aquí que multiplica a 2
por r
2 ok eso es muy importante lo único que
estoy haciendo tomándome esta igualdad
de kim y ojo ten cuidado este 2 también
cuenta este 2 es lo mismo que este 2 ok
de aquí ya tengo una ecuación la cual me
dice cuánto vale r una comparación de
dos así que de aquí vamos a despejar a
qué te parece si despejamos a r 1
entonces voy a bajar un poco todo esto
de aquí y voy a seguirle justo con este
problema
de aquí voy a obtener que dos veces pin
por r 1 es igual a 4 a 4 y por r2 ok y
de aquí ya podemos cancelar algunas
cosas pin con pitt se va y 4 entre 2 y
este 2 lo paso para acá me queda que r 1
es igual a dos veces r
o espera este está acá abajo a dos veces
r2 lo único que hice fue dividir todo
entre dos y esta igualdad me va a servir
bastante porque ya tengo esta igualdad y
tengo también esta ecuación de aquí así
que si sustituyó justo aquí voy a poder
obtener lo que buscaba que es el valor
de rd 2 así que vamos a hacerlo
ya tengo esta de aquí me va a servir
bastante tengo esta de camps y dice r 2
r2 más r 1 es igual a 6 que es la
distancia que hay desde aquí hasta que
toda esta distancia ok pero yo sé que
reúno es dos veces cerrados así que
vamos a sustituir y voy a utilizar este
color y tengo que r uno es dos veces r 2
entonces me queda r 2 r 2 más 2 veces de
2 es igual a 6 y de aquí
déjame bajar un poco más la pantalla de
aquí ya podemos obtener el valor de 2
por qué porque 3 veces
r2 esto es igual a 6
r2 es igual a 6 entre 3 lo cual es 2 de
lujo
entonces ya tengo el valor de 2 que es
justo lo que yo quería el valor de rd 2
es 2 entonces déjenme subir la pantalla
para ponerlo aquí si subimos la pantalla
un poco más
empezamos justo aquí ya sé que r 2 r2
vale 2 y como lo obtuve bueno para
obtener el re 2 date cuenta que lo que
hice fueron dos cosas importantes 1
darme cuenta que esta distancia valía 6
por lo tanto la suma de los dos radios
vale 6 eso está más sencillo y número 2
fijarme en el segundo dato que me da el
problema que la circunferencia 1 o el
perímetro del círculo de amarillo es
igual a dos veces el perímetro de la
circunferencia de color azul o dos veces
2 y antes de entrar en pánico con esta
ecuación que tengo aquí primero calculé
quién era ese uno a comparación de este
radio uno después calculé quién era ese
2 a comparación de este radio 2 jones y
es la igualdad para que me diera una
igualdad de este radio uno conforme al
radio 2 que es justo lo que tengo
es justo lo que encontramos aquí que la
radio 1 es igual a 2 veces el radio 2
ahora también había otra forma de verlo
tal vez un poco más rápida y tal vez
menos intuitiva pero si tú lo logras ver
desde un principio está de lujo
tú puedes decir bueno si la
circunferencia de amarillo es dos veces
la circunferencia de color azul
entonces el radio 1 debe de ser dos
veces el radio 2 y si tú logras ver eso
está de lujo el radio 1
debe de ser igual a 2 veces el radio 2
para que se cumpla esto de aquí y ya de
aquí te saltas de un paso porque
entonces solamente podría sustituir en
nuestra ecuación de aquí y encontrar el
valor de r 2 eso está mucho más fácil
pero la única condición es que te des
cuenta desde un principio que se cumple
esta relación si es dos veces el
perímetro de esta circunferencia se
cumple que es dos veces el radio que es
justo lo que nosotros sacamos acá abajo
esto de acá abajo pero bueno problema
número tres vamos a borrar la pantalla y
vamos el problema número cuatro que por
cierto está lleno de puntos tiene muchos
muchos puntos así que voy a hacerlos así
que tomemos por aquí
al eje
ok y tenemos por aquí al eje x
ok algo más o menos así que voy a decir
que este es mi hija jane éste es mi x y
tengo un montón de puntos así que voy a
poner los tengo por aquí el punto b
ahorita me fue las escalas tengo por
aquí el punto am o que tengo por aquí al
punto ok y tengo por aquí el punto de
algo más o menos por acá por acá hasta
el punto de por último por acá está el
punto sea ok y me dicen cuál de los
siguientes puntos cumple la relación
del valor absoluto de x menos el valor
absoluto de y esto es igual a 3 y yo sé
que no te he puesto una escala justo en
este momento pero quiero que hagamos un
poco de idea intuitiva de qué es lo que
me está diciendo esta expresión aquí me
dice que cuando yo me tomo la diferencia
entre el valor de x y el valor de james
me de 3 o dicho otra manera podemos
pensarlo como el valor absoluto de x el
valor absoluto de x le salve x al origen
la distancia que deje al origen eso es
lo que representa el valor absoluto de
la distancia que tenemos de que es el
origen
- la distancia que tenemos de ella al
origen sea igual a 3 y para esto es
forzoso que el valor de x sea más grande
que el valor de jeff sea negativo o sea
positivo el valor absoluto de x tiene
que ser más grande que el valor absoluto
de iu y eso quiere decir a que este
punto por ejemplo tenemos más altura que
lo que tenemos de largo nuestro valor y
es más grande que el valor en x y por lo
tanto éste no funciona y de igual manera
para este nuestro valor en y es mucho
más grande que nuestro valor en x y esto
tampoco funcionaría para este para este
paso más o menos lo mismo si me fijo
aquí en x y me fijo a king james éste
tampoco funcionaria y de una manera
intuitiva y muy rápida antes de fijarnos
en la escala nos podemos darnos cuenta
que el índice ya ni es son la respuesta
correcta entonces solamente tenemos a b
y adem pero lo que queremos es que la
diferencia entre los valores de x a
comparación de la diferencia de los
valores de y sea
es ya quien de parece ser muy poca
diferencia yo tengo algo por aquí a
comparación de algo por aquí y se ve que
esto no es una diferencia muy grande a
esta diferencia de esto por lacan a esto
para acá y de hecho si nosotros nos
fijamos en el inciso b nos vamos a dar
cuenta que aquí tengo 1 2 3 y 4 estamos
en el -4 y aquí en que estamos en el
menos uno es decir estamos en el menos
cuatro como menos 1 b es el punto menos
cuatro coma menos uno y ahora sí ya
podemos ver que este punto si cumple
esta relación el valor absoluto de menos
cuatro a esto le quito el valor absoluto
de menos uno esto va a ser igual a 4
menos uno lo cual es lo mismo que 3 y de
lujo este se cumple esta relación como
el absoluto por lo tanto mi respuesta es
el sisbén y bueno lo importante de no
haberse puesto escalas era para
descartar a estos tres de una manera
intuitiva y que entendías mejor que
representaba esta expresión que tengo
aquí pero ya está tenemos la respuesta
del problema número
y también ya nos quedamos sin tiempo así
que para no hacer otro problema vamos a
terminar este vídeo aquí y nos vemos en
el siguiente vídeo